what is that what else you got there
that's nice you've got your Wi-Fi on you
are ready if I ever have a child this
will be my child
right here hi bad okay control room here
in line waiting for the iPad I got here
around 7:00 something this is the I did
not pre-order my iPad line and this is
the I did pre-order
[Music]
near downtown services girl pretty
excited they just revealed the windows
about a half hour to go to like to touch
your life Jenna sloggin
iPad insanely you gonna get my iPad I
don't think yeah I don't like the
channel like there champ hello why
didn't you join any what the vendor yeah
seriously
yeah that's what that was these dogs
they want the iPad
move it we're moving we're moving look
he's got an iPad these guys iPad
[Music]
okay you can stop now okay we're here
you're so close to getting an iPad this
loves street unboxing here
look at iPad get ready a Hugh breathe
just in with nice to meet you I'm
telling you have to go because I can't
[Applause]
I can't breathe right now
I'm shaking
I played with it for an hour now
[Applause]
[Music]
so I got an iPad and I'm gonna open it
okay so I'm opening up the iPad here
it's got this nice box hey art this is
it right here
iPad it is so fun like Christmas okay
I'm turning it on
I think oh it's just like a big - oh
it's you hello
there's gonna be so many of these jokes
vimax
oh look at the cute little are you gonna
get a 3G - Alex almost like oh oh yeah
that's it
oh that's it that's all I need it yeah
you just needed it connection oh my god
this is beautiful
this is seriously all this screen is
just cool see here it is a my iPad it's
working a little this beautiful little
it makes me feel like a scrap
hi guys alright so here at sight glass
square a launch party I guess you could
call it
today's Square is launching officially
on the iPad as you guys probably saw
it's the credit card payment for your
iPhone iPad all that fun stuff so we're
gonna go in
and the
[Music]
just a copy know where